oui en de montluc je trouve quand même
qu'entendre à 5 minutes de distance
henri guaino avec sa fougue et son
ardeur gaulliste au sens le plus pur du
terme et francis babec je connais bien
qui est un ancien du cds exprimer une
ligne libérale sociale et européennes ça
montre bien que nous sommes dans un
parti dans une famille des républicains
dans laquelle nous pouvons parler et
dans laquelle nous pouvons construire
quelles que soient les identités qui
étaient les selles des uns ou des autres
hier je voudrais dire aux militants ici
et c'est un message que je passe au nom
de mes adhérents du nord que nous
n'accepterons pas de nous laisser
confisquer la question du projet
politique par un débat de primaires
uniquement la télévision jugé par
monsieur giesbert ou par madame saint
cricq que je remercie nicolas sarkozy
d'organiser ce débat de le porter dans
toutes les fédérations pour qu'elle
puisse en juger et que l'on puisse se
déterminer parce que les républicains
c'est pas quelque chose de muda
consistant c'est une ligne politique
c'est un destin ce sont des valeurs et
ce sont des choses qu'il faut partager
un mois francis sur la côte et liberté
libérons les énergies on en a déjà
beaucoup parlé
plusieurs orateurs se sont exprimés sur
le côté européen et nation le président
sarkozy lui-même ce matin je pense a dit
des choses très importantes
la nation c'est fondamental et ce n'est
pas incompatible avec la communauté de
destin européenne le tout est de le
mettre dans le bon ordre et de commencer
par la nation et sur le social moi qui
ai beaucoup travaillé comme ministre à
la fois de nicolas sarkozy et de jacques
chirac sur ces questions là je peux vous
dire que nous devons refonder
radicalement notre modèle social
on peut pas continuer à accepter que
nous soyons le pays d'europe qui dépend
sont en pourcentage de notre produit
intérieur brut le plus d'argent pour le
social et que nous faisons partie des
trois pays européens qui n'ont pas
réussi à inverser la courbe du chômage
d'accord
on a hérité de monsieur hollande on n'a
pas eu de bol mais quand même ça veut
dire que structurellement nous devons
revoir notre modèle social différemment
que beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre sont
dans la gouvernance de notre pays que la
question de la gestion paritaire des
organismes sociaux de cette complexité
regarder le rsa avec les caf les ccas
les départements pôle emploi qui fait
qu'on est dans un circuit ubuesque qui
coûte très cher n'est plus possible que
la gouvernance nos collectivités
territoriales on en a parlé de brigitte
barèges n'est plus possible non plus et
qu'on doit aller au pragmatisme et à
l'efficacité et bien moi je vais vous
dire quand j'entends henri guaino et
quand j'entends ce témoignage d'un
ancien centriste qui se rassemblent dans
l'est républicain
j'ai fort confiance en l'avenir et je
remercie nicolas sarkozy